Nisha was a devastating critic of,
I would say dogmatic Christianity,
Christianity as it was
instantiated in institutions,
I suppose.
Although he,
he's a very paradoxical
thinker because for example,
one of the things neat just said was that
he didn't believe that the scientific
revolution would have ever got off the
ground if it hadn't been for Christianity
and more specifically for Catholicism
because he believed that over the course
of really a thousand years,
the European mind,
so to speak,
had to train itself to interpret
everything that was known within a single
coherent framework,
coherent if you accept the initial axioms,
a single coherent framework and so neat,
you believe that that
Catholicism Nation of,
of,
of the phenomena of life and of history
produced the kind of mine that was then
capable of transcending that it's dogmatic
foundations and then concentrating on
something else,
which in this particular case
happened to be the natural world.
And so Nietzsche,
you believe that in some sense
Christianity died at its own hand.
It had spent a very long period of time
trying to attune people to the necessity
of the truth.
You know,
absent the corruption and all of that,
that's always part of any human endeavor.
And then the truth,
the spirit of the truth that was developed
by Christianity turned on the roots
of Christianity.
And everyone woke up
and said something like,
or thought something like,
well how is it that we came
to believe any of this?
Um,
it's like waking up one day and noting,
noting that you really don't know
why you put a Christmas tree up,
but you've been doing it for a long time.
And that's what people do.
And in know,
there are reasons that
Christmas trees came about,
but the,
what would you say?
The ritual lasts long after the
reasons have been forgotten.
So now Nicha although he was a critic
of Christianity and also a champion of,
of its disciplinary capacity,
because you see,
the other thing that needs you believed
was that it was not possible to be free
in some sense,
unless you,
unless you had been a slave.
And,
and by that he meant that you don't go
from childhood to full fledged adult
individuality.
You go from childhood to
a state of discipline,
which you might think is akin to slavery,
to self imposed slavery,
that that would be the best scenario
where you have to discipline yourself to
become something specific before you might
be able to retain the generality that
you had as a child.
And he believed that Christianity had
played that role for Western civilization.
Um,
bought in the late 18 hundreds,
he announced that God was dead.
And you often hear of that
as something triumphant.
But for Nietzsche it wasn't
because he was too nuanced.
The thinker to be that simple minded,
see,
neat.
Yep.
Understood that this is something I'm
going to try to make clear as that
we,
there's,
there's a very large amount that we don't
know about the structure of experience
that we don't know about reality and we
have our articulated representations of
the world.
And then you can think of outside of that,
there are things we know absolutely
nothing about and there's a buffer between
them.
And those are the things we sort of know
something about and we don't know them
in an articulated way.
Here's an example.
You know,
sometimes you're arguing with one of your,
someone close to you and
they're in a bad mood,
you know,
and uh,
they're being touchy and unreasonable and
you keep the conversation up and maybe
all of a sudden they,
you know,
they get angry.
Maybe they cry and then when they cry
they figure out what they're angry about.
And it has nothing to do with you
even though you might've been.
What precipitated the argument?
You know,
one that's an interesting phenomena as
far as I'm concerned because it means
that people can know things at one level
without being able to speak what they
know at another.
And so in some sense,
the thoughts rise up from the body and
they do that in moods and they do that in
images and they do that and actions.
And we have all sorts of ways that we
understand before we understand in a fully
articulated manner.
And so we have this articulated
space that we can all discuss.
And then outside of that,
we have something that's more akin
to a dream that we're embedded in.
And it's an emotional dream
that we're embedded in.
And that's based at least
in part on her actions.
I'll describe that later.
And then outside of that is what we
don't know anything about at all.
And in that dream,
that's where the mystics live and that's
where the artists live and they're a
mediators between the absolute unknown
and the things we know for sure.
And
you see
what that means in some sense is what
we know is established on a form of
knowledge that we don't really understand
and that if those two things are out
of sync,
so you might say if our articulated
knowledge is out of sync with our dream,
then we become dissociated internally.
We think things we don't act out and we
act out things we don't dream and that
produces a kind of sickness of the spirit
and and that sickness of the spirit it
see it.
It's cure is something like an integrated
system of belief and representation.
And then people turn to
things like ideologies,
which I regardless parasites
on an underlying religious
substructure to try to
organize their thinking and
then that's a catastrophe.
And that's what Nisha,
Nisha foresaw.
You see?
He knew that when we knocked the slats
out of the base of Western civilization
by destroying this representation,
this is God ideal,
let's say,
that we would destabilize
and move back and forth.
They,
between nihilism,
let's say in the extremes of videology,
he was particularly concerned
about radical left ideology
and no one believed in
it and predicted this in the late 18
hundreds which is really an absolute
intellectual tour.
De Force of staggering magnitude
predicted that in the 20th century that
hundreds of millions of people would
die because of the replacement of these
underlying dreamlike
structures with this rational,
rational,
but deeply incorrect
representation of the world.
And you know,
we've been oscillating back and forth
between the left and right in some sense
ever since.
And you know,
with some good sprinkling of
nihilism in there and despair,
some sense that's the situation of the
modern western person in increasingly of
people in general.